The word hit us
like you're hit with the, with them.
[inaudible]
and we're like, that cannot be
art. That cannot be our son.
I'm Janet and Ron. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab in our story today begins with
a boy and that boy a is going to vanish.
Not In the thin air, but to a place
that we know very, very little about.
And if you're the parent of that boy,
what do you do if your child is
falling away from everything you know,
how do you find him?
How do you get him back?
So part of this tale we got from
Ron SAS kinds, new, wonderful book,
life animated. And some of you may have
heard it, some not. Let's start. Where,
uh, were Ron started, uh,
for him it began around 1993 and uh,
and it was an exciting time.
Well, we're going into Owens around for,
what is his last night
in the crib? Nike's.
I still can't, you still can't watch it.
Can you tell us about your crib
own? Do you like your crib?
Yeah. Do you know where
you're sleeping tomorrow?
What kind of better you and
Walter going to sleep. Then
in 1993, this last guy and family decided
to make a big move run and his wife,
Cornelia, Cornelia Suskind and
their two sons, Walt and Owen.
Walter is about five and
Owen is about two and a half.
They decide to relocate from
Boston to Washington DC. You know,
I had the senior National
Affairs job at the Journal.
Can I say Navy night? Kind
of a dream job. I love you.
Lots of excitement. Have a
nice last night near Cribby.
So they make the move and as soon
as they arrive in Washington,
we start sort of noticing something's
amiss. Their youngest son, Owen,
who to that point had been
a totally normal chatty,
almost three year olds hitting
all of his markers. Suddenly
it goes sideways.
Maybe the very first thing that
happened was he stopped sleeping.
He stopped sleeping, he stopped
eating. He was very fussy initially.
They figured, well, it's
gotta be the move. Um,
and then we start losing eye contact.
Then he starts losing motor skills.
He can hold his cup
slipping out of his hand.
His gait became very odd. Um,
and he was sort of looked like a drunken
sailor walking around the house and
then he stopped speaking
bit by bit by bit.
This is all compressed into a few
months. A few months. Really. Yeah.
What could have occurred,
could he have banged his head than
just did something toxic? You know,
first you hit the regular
pediatrician and he's gone. No,
they sent us to a center. There was a
woman there who sits them down and uh,
she says the word autism. What did
the word mean to you at that moment?
It meant rain, man,
Dustin. I'm a good driver.
Until we saw and were
like, that cannot be our,
that cannot be our son.
You know, it was just terrifying.
Now in reporting this story,
we ended up going off in a
variety of different directions,
but we did visit one place where we
got a glimpse, just the here and again,
what parents like Ron and
Cornelia must have felt back then.
We visited a school here in
Manhattan called the Rebecca School.
It's a really unique school
for children with autism,
other developmental delays.
There's little kids in their h four all
the way up to I think even 21 every kid
that you meet in the school is
different. Autism is a many,
many flavored things,
but the overwhelming sense you get walking
the halls there is that each of these
kids is kind of
locked away a little bit. Just
they don't know how to be with.
Okay.
Like Kelsey paget and I, we got there
during lunch and one of the rooms,
I don't know, maybe you should
describe this. Yeah, there was this,
we went to this one classroom
where there was this,
this one boy who really stood out. He
was about six years old and he had this,
this big mob of uh,
black hair and he was just
standing there at the table holding
an apple apple, you want
to eat that and just
sobbing when you eat your apple,
you don't want to eat the apple woo woo.
And the director of the
school, Tina McCort,
she was there and she just stayed with
the boy and really like tried to be there
with him, but there was
nothing she could do.
[inaudible] goes apple. We
don't want to say with heron,
it was hard to walk.
Okay.
Because you don't know how to help.
Oh,
so that's the challenge, right?
There's a kid who actually can't tell
you what's upsetting to them, right?
That's guilt hippy. The school's clinical
director could be that he physically,
he actually doesn't know where he is in
space. Maybe if that's, if we were being
drone out of an airplane,
right? You're just tumbling.
You don't know where your body
is a, it's a thunderstorm.
So you only see things in flashes. Right?
So now the world is totally
frightening. It's totally overwhelming.
I mean, I do remember the drive home from
that, from that terrible day. I don't,
I blocked that out. Well, just,
I mean I just remember, you know,
you and I driving home in silence with
Owen in the back and I just felt like,
you know, there was no, there's no,
like they had no idea if the Owen they
knew was in there or if he was just kind
of lost to them, like gone.
Now keep in mind this was 1994, uh,
we knew even less about
autism than we know now.
We still have no idea what causes autism.
But then the prevailing wisdom
seemed to be that kids with autism,
they couldn't feel emotion. They had no
capacity to empathize with other people.
This was way before the
neurodiversity movement,
like actually right around the moment
when autism was becoming a spectrum for
the first time.
That's just happening in 1994 just
starting, barely starting. Yeah.
At that point Owen was Belfour, was
he active or was he always very,
he was hyperactive. A lot of self
stimulatory behavior, you know,
hand flapping, running around and uh,
Cornelia and Ron say that
when they would call him,
it was as if he didn't even hear them.
We're hoping he's hearing, you know,
but he's not really responding when
you needed him to come to the table,
we basically have to go and
lead him by the hand and,
or pick them up and bring them over.
Huh. And he was down to one word,
which was juice.
So the only thing he was doing was
drinking juice for about a year. And also,
you know, there was the Disney movies,
so he would sit for, he would sit
for, and for television entertainment.
He wouldn't sit for the whole
movie for sure, but he would,
that would be the one thing that he would
sit for quietly for periods I'd been
through because he didn't sleep.
So at night I was usually
up with him all night,
thrashing around and it's Owen Watch
one Disney movie after another after
another, not sleeping
at all. That word juice.
It seemed to expand just a little bit.
He began to repeat the word juice.
Servos, juice Servos, juicer vose wait,
so is he saying juicer foes to service
two through five but you don't know what
first what that is? No, no, we think
it's juice. Cornelia's like I said,
does he seem to want more juice? And
she's like, no, I gave him more juicy,
didn't seem to want it.
And Ron says he would say that word over
and over for weeks and they had no idea
what it meant until he was about a year
or in a month after the symptoms have
started. One night,
all four of them are together in the
living room and we're watching the little
mermaid, I'm dot. Not My bed does say.
And at a certain point,
oh, who's got the remote?
He starts rewinding the
movie back a little bit.
The lady was with to rewatch
the scene. That's typical.
So I will knows that her work,
the remote while kind of showed him how
to do it and he took to that and he's
rewinding the part where Ariel,
hi, become human or protagonist,
I'll never be with my
father's sisters again.
Wants to become human to get
her man Eric. That's right.
And the see which Ursula
[inaudible] says it will,
it will cost you tough choices
and the prices are voice,
your voice, my voice.
You've got it. Sweet cakes.
And then all of a sudden
Ariel and first solar
and this park, the three land again,
again, no day.
It's like, oh and stop.
Rewinding. Just play the movie.
I won't leave after the third rewind.
Critical. He says, oh,
[inaudible],
well it's not juice does
not choose. It's just, ah.
I said, what? Just your voice?
At which point I'm like,
I grabbed the shoulders and I'm like,
just your voice. Just your voice.
And he can stay. It's called
juicer, vose juicer, juicer.
Rose and Walters are jumping in the
bed crying and laughing and [inaudible]
jumping to the feeling you chose that
phrase for a reason. Oh, that's what we,
that's of course
immediately what we thought.
He's trying to tell us
something that like,
he has things to say but he
just can't say it's his voice.
In other words, he's in there, he's in
there because he's trying to talk to us.
So we run to the doctor, very trusted
guy and he's like, ah, you know,
sit down, let's talk. And he
says something called Echolalia.
It's echoing sounds that
their auditory processing,
their ability to process sound
speech by inquiry goes haywire.
And so they just repeat the sound and
we've seen so he doesn't know what it
means. And he's like, probably not
echolalia. It's what it sounds like.
Echo what it sounds like. Echo. I said
like a parrot. They're like, yeah, yeah,
a parrot.
So we go from Helen Keller
to the pet store parrot.
Okay.
Life goes on and years go by
where he's murmuring a lot of jibberish.
We might be able to
decipher from some movie,
maybe by six he's got, you
know, three words, sentences.
I want juice, just, you know,
one and a half year old
speech corns there full time.
24 seven Ron's working around
the clock in a kind of frenzy.
It pay for all of the therapists
and we're fighting it out.
Basically they see tiny,
tiny bits of progress,
but no more breakthroughs
until the ones about six and a half and
Walt is nine and Walter gets a little
emotional in his ninth birthday.
I'm not sure, maybe the anxiety of
the moment of the attention of it.
This is Walt Suskind. And
how old are you now? Well,
I'm 25 your voice is so much
deeper than I imagined it would be.
People usually have,
they're like 10 minutes.
If it's their first time meeting
me asks if I'm faking my voice,
I'd have to assure them
this is not in effect.
This is how I sound. Any case,
Walt has his ninth birthday
and his friends come over
and then after the party he's out in
the hammock in the yard and he's kind of
crying a little bit and as
it was, right, they were just
kind of strange days for me,
like sensory overload in a way and walks
in after Walter is emotional and we're
in the kitchen and he seems to kind of
look back and forth between the two of us
in like there's something he
wants to say to this point,
Owen had only said three word sentences,
but in this moment, according to Ron,
he looks at us and says,
[inaudible]
Walter doesn't want to grow up like
Mowgli or a Peter Pan said full sentences,
full thing, whole thing. Wow.
I mean literally it
was like a thunderbolt,
a lightning bolt went through the
kitchen and Owen goes, runs off in some,
you know, reverie, whatever.
And we look at each other and like
the luck that was that, you know,
this is his first complex sense
or thought that's been expressed.
And it's a subtle one actually.
Cause he's taking three different
characters to from a movie,
one from real life. And he's putting
them together. Saran is like, ah,
I got to follow this.
So he goes up to Owen's room and I see
Owen on the bed looking at a Disney book
and I see on the carpet are
some of his puppets and he,
and one of them is Jago
from a, from Aladdin,
the plush toy, you know, which is the
$98 one that goes up to your elbow.
And I grabbed it and I put it on,
on my arm right up to the elbow and I
crawl along in the rug and I throw the
bedspread kind of over my head and
just edge up to the edge of the bed.
And I pushed the puppet up through
the crease in the bedspread.
And so now they're face to face,
Owen and Jago and I'm looking up
through the crease, sort of up my arm.
And I talked to him as Jago.
Now this is an easy voice. It's
Gilbert Gottfried's voice. I mean,
anyone can do this. I say salt, I'll
wait, I'll wait. I'll wait. How,
how does it feel to be you?
And he turns to the puppet,
like he's a bumping into an old friend
and he says, oh, not good. Uh, I'm lonely.
And it was his voice. Wow. And so I say,
so when did, when did you and
I become such good friends?
And he says, when I watched the
Latin and you made me laugh,
and we go back and forth like this
for four or five more exchanges.
And then I hear Owen clear his
throat, like, are like that.
And then all of a sudden
I hear him say back,
I love the way all foul little
mind works. He said, what?
I love the way all FAO little mind
works. That's Jafar the villain.
Ya'll goes the villainous sidekick
to Jafar, the villain of the Latin.
That's Jeff. That's the next line from
Jafar youth lead into a square movie.
You're asking for me to respond as Jago.
Did you know the next time I didn't
know the next line at that point I just
jumped out from under the
bedspreads. What's going on?
Whoa.
I was glad to know. They felt like,
okay, he, he is, he is in there.
I mean despite everything that
they had been told about autism,
Owen was in there and somehow these
Disney characters are in there
with him. It doesn't take
us long that, you know,
we start what we called the
basement sessions where we say to,
let's see how far this can go.
Couple of times a week we go down in
the basement and start playing at scenes
and we do it the first time
we do it with the jungle book,
which is a movie he
was into at that point.
And then I did 101
Dalmatians down on the piece,
Peter Pan Towards the stone. So
will you, we kind of ran the gamut.
I mean pretty much we'd
watch any and every
Disney movie there was what?
Describe to these guys.
What was the like when mom and I started
doing voices and Walter felt amazed.
Felt amazed. Who? Who was amazed?
You were amazed or they was
amazed. This is Owen SAS Guide.
He's 23 now. Why were you
amazed? I was so surprised
by my family.
I could hear them respond better.
You're saying that when, when everybody
was acting out the Disney movies,
suddenly you could hear
them better, right?
So when people wouldn't talk to you,
not in the Disney movies, do you,
what do you remember
about how they sounded
a little weird? Yeah.
Jibberish and rubbish.
Huh? Do you remember how you felt?
A little worried. You told
mom once that you were scared.
I was scared.
Okay.
Why did it feel good to watch
them over and over again?
That you kept wanting to watch
How did that feel to you? It felt
comforting. Comforting, felt comforting.
Why? Because it would help me with
reducing my autism.
How does a movie help a
boy in Owen's condition?
Stay tuned and we'll, we'll
attempt some explanations.
This is Candace currently
calling from her bicycle.
Radiolab is supported in
part by the National Science
Foundation and by Alfred p
Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org thank you.
Okay.
Radiolab is supported by swell,
investing and impact investing
platform.
What have you could invest in our planet
while also investing in your financial
future? Think about that. Our
resources are diminishing.
Our population is growing.
Companies solving today's biggest
challenges will be tomorrow's leaders.
Swell helps you invest in high growth
companies working towards clean water when
you will bill energy and green technology.
It's a market opportunity
you can feel good about.
Get a $50 bonus when you open your
account@swellinvesting.com slash Radiolab
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and today a story about a kid
named Owen and a condition that no one
can quite pin down. Now
we just heard that Owen,
when he watches Disney movies,
he feels comforted in that somehow the
movie seems to dial down his autism.
We're like, why would that be crazy next?
How could a Disney movie or any movie
really make that much difference?
Um, can you hear me okay?
I can really pretty well.
I'm just gonna we ended up taking the
question to this guy, Simon Baron. Karin,
he's a leading researcher in
autism and yes, he is the cousin of
this guy is my wife
and I'm the director of the autism
research center at Cambridge Uni.
Bursty and Simon told us a couple
of different things. First of all,
he says that in the last few decades,
our whole notion of what is happening
in the mind of a child with autism has
totally changed. We've sort of
tossed out the rain man idea.
The idea that um,
people with autism lack some in our life.
I think that's completely false.
It's not necessarily that they
can't feel emotion or empathy.
It says not at all. It's
often a decoding problem.
Like they have trouble decoding all
of the information that's coming in.
I mean some studies have found that a lot
of kids with autism literally have too
many synapses in their brain.
So it might be the world
is just coming in too loud.
I think often people with autism
feel very lost and confused
as to a little predictability
in the social world. You know,
people come and go, they that
no two days are the same.
People say things unexpectedly,
they do things unexpectedly.
Then people with autism who seem
to need a lot of predictability.
We spoke to temple granted, uh,
the well known author and autism
advocate and here's how she put it.
That was a little kid. I wanted to
feel the nice feeling of being held,
but there was just too much overwhelming
stimulation. Your loud sounds hurt.
My years,
like the volume control on
touch and hearing was way, way,
way turned on.
And one of the reasons why I withdrew
into things like dribbling sand to my
hands is I could shut and
shut out the hurtful sound
as a temple grant and explained it to us.
A kid with autism gravitating to
something like bus or knowing every single
effect about every
dinosaur that ever lived.
That is just a way to slow things down
and make the world predictable so that it
happens the same way every time.
And as Simon Baron Cohen puts it,
in Owen's case, he had these Disney
movies that you could play Oh,
over and over and over and over.
And then the fact that it's,
you know, it's sad, it's
not just repetition,
but it's repetition about
human action. Jasmine,
where are you out in the
Menagerie? Hurry. Yeah.
That creates a kind of structure to
be able to look at human behavior.
You know, in the real world, there's
no opportunity to rewind the movie.
Whereas in the world of movies,
you can watch the same Disney cartoon
a hundred times or a thousand times and
you can almost go frame by frame
like a literary critic or a film critic.
You could really analyze the action to
understand, okay, that's what happened.
And that's, that's what
caused him to do what he did.
And to that, the element of Music
[inaudible] we spoke with a
professor, Geraldine Dawson,
a neuroscience professor at Duke who
guessed that maybe it's not just the
repetition that made the difference,
but the repetition with music.
One of the things that we've learned
from neuroscience is that music activates
emotional centers in
our brain. And in fact,
it's pretty reliable that certain
kinds of music make us feel,
no frightened, make us feel happy,
make us feel worried and
so forth. Now she says,
when scientists have done brain
scans of kids with autism, they found
that during kind of normal interactions,
people with autism don't necessarily
activate those emotional centers of the
brain areas like the Amygdala.
But during the experience of music
[inaudible]
um, the,
those areas of the brain did
become activated in a way
that was very much like a
typical person.
So it might be that while Owen was sort
of forensically examining these moments
of Disney movies,
it was the Disney music that was
binding those moments to feelings.
So we could know like, oh,
when a person looks like that,
that's when they're happening
and the person looks like that.
That's when they're sad. However it works.
Simon Baron Cohen thinks
it's at least plausible.
Okay.
Is He using the movie as a scaffold to
make sense of the much greater complexity
of natural life
and that's what got to run sky.
Wow.
This is a whole new planet here and maybe
this Disney ish therapy that they use
with Owen might be a whole new approach
to treating kids with autism instead of
the one size fits all model of the sit
in the class and here are the things
you're supposed to know
to be a working member of.
Instead it's like go with their
passion, follow them in there. It's,
it's a pathway,
the brain finding a way to
get to what people need,
which is interaction
and emotional wholeness.
You're, I want you to sing the
song for them. [inaudible] dessert.
Visco Grina it's about the this lake.
You're [inaudible] up there,
but that is a big mistake.
Just do a car too.
Over the years,
sometimes down in the basement with the
family or sometimes even in doctor's
offices, Owen started to improvise.
He'd go off script and use the characters.
He knew so well to explain
how he was feeling.
I'll do the C. Dot.
But the Dow quid is with
the take for me. Yeah,
and as you were thinking about all this
and asking ourselves, you know newt,
well, right, if this
works with Disney movies,
which are very emotional
and clear, what do you,
how do you do this with
paper clips or bus schedules?
And as the questions kept coming,
we ran into inevitably a counter
reaction to run story and this,
we didn't expect the story. It's
great. It's a wonderful story.
But the fact is most, I mean onto
the danger with a, with a book,
with any book including life animated,
is that it's going to give the impression
to a lot of people that this is the
answer. You know?
It's kind of what that psychologist and
journalist David Royko and he warned us
that like with autism we still don't
really know much and we don't have yet.
And a body of established science
and all the anecdotes you're hearing,
they're just anecdotes. If you've
known one person with autism,
you've known one person with autism that
he says it's really all you can say and
to take one person's experience and
generalize on it, it's a mistake. Okay.
A case in point, his son Ben Ben
is turning 21 years old today.
Oh my God. Happy Birthday
to him. Thanks. And uh, Yo,
Ben is never going to be
able to live independently.
He's never going to have
what anyone considered would
consider a full and normal
life.
Well, Ben has severe autism and is now
living in an assisted living facility.
He was diagnosed around the same
age as Owen, same basic symptoms,
lack of eye contact, sudden loss of speech
with spinning wheels, with ceiling
fans, the whole, the whole package.
Dave says he and his wife tried every
therapy they could afford and a whole lot
they couldn't, but Ben never had any
of those big breakthroughs. Instead,
even as a teenager,
he would hit and he would scratch and
he would bite and he would punch and he
would kick. Honestly,
I was always afraid when Karen and I
would end up having to go to the emergency
room for some reason that, you know,
if they saw her arms that they would
arrest me because I would think I was some
horribly abusive person because
their arms were nothing,
but they were covered with scabs
and scars and scars on scars.
And on top of that, uh, you know,
there'd be the crap, like, like,
like know his pants. Yeah. I mean,
he, he's, he was not, well, you know,
I hate to say it,
but here we are in his 21st birthday
and he's still not 100% reliable when it
comes to the toileting.
And honestly,
the reason we ended up calling Dave is
because he wrote a review of Ron's book
where he said, basically,
it's a great book,
but it's just one more story
of a triumphant happy ending.
And that is not the norm
for many, many people
who experience autism.
You don't have happy
endings. I mean, that's,
that's a sad fact for many
of these families and we're
not expecting in our life
a a happy ending for Ben.
Oh,
people seem to believe that,
that it's dangerous for parents to
have too much hope because what if they
really think it's possible for their
child to progress a huge amount or recover
and then their child doesn't.
We have the other concern.
That's Ron Kaufman of the autism
treatment center of America.
We find that we're not afraid
of so-called false hope.
We're more concerned
about false pessimism.
And here's why. He says
that in 1981 Ron's dad,
Barry and don over with,
he sits down, yeah,
on a local TV show was a very young
Oprah Winfrey and he describes his
experience. Okay.
We had a child who was diagnosed
as incurably ill or hopelessly ill,
something called autism. He
tells how at a really young
age or year and a half old, his son
began to regress and began to flap hands,
lose eye contact, rock back and forth.
And then one day he, his wife decided,
you know what,
we're going to just sit down on the
bathroom floor right next to him and we're
going to rock back and
forth just like him.
And he explains that they did
this over and over and over,
hour after hour until one day his son
turned his head and he actually looked at
us. It took 900 hours before
he ever gave us eye contact on his own.
When he looked at us, we cheered
whose cried this? That
was really big for us,
so somebody else might look
at us and say, you're crazy,
but we're not. We just
got this little boy,
took us 900 friggin hours,
but he just looked at us
for three seconds. My God,
and he went from that to a little boy
now who functions on a near genius level
who talks is communicative, is
loving, and is embracing awesome
and that little boy is run for me.
It just felt like my mother was loving
me and enjoying me and playing with me.
Nowadays in interviews,
run seems to say that maybe his
parents cured him a lot too,
so I actually have never used the word
cure. I don't use that in my lectures.
Youtube videos, no one's ever
actually heard me say that.
What I do say is full recovery,
which is essentially the same thing,
the reason, whatever you call it. Armed
with his heroic story, Ron and his dad,
Barry now run an autism treatment program
that they call sunrise, s o n, right?
People come here from
all around the world.
Let's say my child is severely autistic
and I will sim smile and I'll put out my
hand and I'll shake
their hand and I'll say,
I am so excited for you. Wow,
you are so blessed and you
know what they'll start to do?
They'll cry and I'll say, why are you
crying? No one ever said that to me.
You really say that to parents with a
severely like severely autistic kids.
Severely. I say it
all over the world.
You know, last year
there was a woman named Kelly Stapleton
who was a fairly prominent autism
blogger and I got to know Kelly a bit.
She has a daughter with autism and
one day when her daughter was 14
she locked herself in a van with a
couple of charcoal burners and tried to
commit suicide with her autistic daughter.
You see that in the world
of autism more than I,
I can't think of any
other place you see it.
Dave believes that one of the reasons
you see so many suicides in this
community, and by the way there a
huge debate about this on the web,
but he believes that one of the reasons
you see it so much is that all of these
success stories seem to say to parents
like him did as hard as it can be in it
can be really, really hard.
You're not trying hard enough.
It's depressing. You know, a,
a new bumper sticker, you know,
that's shown up that uh,
autism is awesome and awesome spell like
a u s l m e like kind of like similar
to autism. Um, no, you autism,
it destroys lives is what it
does in our definition of it.
And that's one of the
things that makes it very,
very confusing for people outside the
community to describe what's going on.
Because you now have this situation where
obviously all autism is a spectrum and
so you have all of these different
kids described by the same word
making things even more confusing. Do
you take a child one there, two or three,
that's temple grand and again you're
going to have two kids that look real
severe and I looked real severe
while I was when I was three real,
real severe. And then
you work on these kids,
lots of one-on-one therapy and one kid
you kind of pull them out of it and the
other one you're not able to pull them
out of it and they've all looked the same
at h street.
So if a lot of these kids start out with
the same set of symptoms but they end
up in vastly different
places, no one knows why.
Then as a parent you really have no idea
what is going to happen or how much you
can dare to hope notions of what could
be up the road or what should be.
Now if they pop into my head,
which is rare, I dismiss them.
I have absolutely no idea
because have been down
so many roads that were disappointing.
[inaudible]
and uh, that's next.
hey guys, this is Nathan Sanchez
calling from Santa Clara, California.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org.
Thanks guys.
I'm jet album Ron. I'm
Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
And to continue with the story after
Owen's Disney basement sessions had really
taken off in the Disney
therapy as it were,
seemed to be working and Owen was getting
better and better and better things
took a turn and, and not for the good.
Remind me how old he is at this point.
Uh, 14 1414. Yeah. Ninth. Ninth. Great.
Um, but it was 10th grade. Oh, right.
10th grade. I was it. Yeah, that's right.
That's right. And what happened?
We didn't know what was happening.
You know, we just saw over the months
at Owen was really out of sorts.
You got quiet, kind of withdrawn,
basically stopped doing Disney over this
period. He's losing a lot of weight.
He's not sleeping.
The three of us were scratching our
heads saying what is going on with Owen?
He is really moving into a bad place.
I mean I was actually worried that
he was becoming schizophrenia.
Boy. Yeah,
I still think about that whole scenario
all the time cause we knew something was
wrong with Owen and we
couldn't get it out of him.
This is Owen's older brother Walt again.
And he says when he picked up Owen from
school, he was just a shell of himself.
You'd talk to him.
So I'd pick him up and you've talked
himself in the car and it'd be no note or
you know, it's not true or
something under his breath.
And then at one point I overhear him
in a kind of conversation with Phil,
the sidekick of Hercules
in that movie, Hercules.
Danny Devito does the voice. And
Phil is, you know, like saying kid,
you can take them, you know, you're
kind of stand up for yourself.
That kind of thing that Owen
was saying and I didn't,
I didn't know where to
fit it in. Ron says,
it seemed like Owen was trying to
psych himself up for something.
So he sat down with him on the couch
and he grilled them for an hour until
eventually Owen told him about
his music class at school.
There are two kids in this class who
are Ed kids, emotionally disturbed kids.
So they're not, they're not on the
autistic spectrum. And socially,
they're very, um, on target and they,
um,
basically torment and terrorize him
for six months of that school year,
unbeknownst to us and
unbeknownst to the school. Um,
what did they do? They sat on either
side of him and basically said,
you know, we're going to kill you.
We're going to kill your parents.
And those two bullies
lied and bullied me badly.
I mean,
right then you were in a very bad spot
and you couldn't tell me your mom or
anyone, right? Because what
happened? The bully said, what?
Burn your house down if
what if you tell. Right.
And Owen was so literal, as
are so many autistic kids,
he believed that they literally
meant they were going to come in,
burn his house down.
Then there's an extraordinary moment in
the middle of this where Walter picks
him up and Owens starts to
think of, go through a calculus.
The bully said, if you tell
your parents about what we said,
we'll burn your house down. But they
said nothing about your brother.
Ah,
and so he's, he sees like an opening.
Yeah. And so did you tell him no
I didn't. No, I didn't. I why?
Why not? Cause I'm afraid
he would beat them up.
I didn't want that,
Walter, at this point, you know,
as a football player and you know,
he looks like Hercules to Owen.
And Owen later describes to us this
thinking that if he tells Walter,
um, that Walter will, uh,
hurt the kid and maybe killed a kid.
And in Disney,
none of the heroes actually
kill any of the villains.
No. Walter was the hero. You were
afraid he was going to do what?
Kill. Yeah, it's wrong. Did
you ever talk to Walt about it?
A little bit later after it happened,
I just remember finding out. Yeah.
And it was like a combination of
like rage and helplessness that
I literally just thought of what I
would've done to that kid if I'd,
if Owen had told me I really
wanted to kill that kid. I mean,
um, you know, um, I'm his protector
in a way. Your,
you were kind of pre Walter was worried
about protecting you in that time. Yeah,
in a way it was me that was doing what?
Protecting myself and who
else and my brother. Right.
And Wild on the wall.
You're protecting Walter.
So here you had this moment where it
looked like Owen was sliding backwards.
But according to Ron, it might've
actually been his greatest leap forward.
His most profound moment
of empathy these days. Oh,
in his 23 just turned 23 a few months
ago. And Are you in love right now? Yes,
I am. What the girl made dreams and Molly,
she and I graduated
from review last month.
This has been a three year program called
getting ready for the outside world
grow. Yeah. And so he'll be graduating
from the, from the entire program. Yup.
Yup. And often on sound. And now
me, her and our other two friends,
John and Julie also go to school are all
gonna move and live up life and Hyannis
I think what his wife living in a
penalty forever. And what is it,
what kind of day to spend adult
independent living program
as we were talking,
it was hard not to wonder how independent
will Owen be because that's the
question that's in front of the
SAS guys now. Especially Walt.
I think what scares me sometimes is
okay,
kind of just having to go it alone in
a lot of ways and at the same time just
being there for,
sorry. Um,
there's some daunting things
ahead and um, you know,
I'll just have to be ready to
take these things on. Kind of
no wonder you don't like
birthdays. Makes Sense.
That makes clear, well,
it's a tough one. I mean,
well if there's like an, I said
to me at one point, he's like,
is it always going to be
Disney? I mean, forever.
And I'm like, God, I know. Well, but
we talked, we talked to him about,
you know, about everything,
about, you know,
our will and who will be s you know,
how he figures into everything.
All the efforts of what we're trying to
do and have been doing for all this time
is to,
one of our favorite movies is the jungle
book cause Mowgli's it's this quest
but there's animal sidekicks
to get him to the man village.
What we have been doing all this time and
what we're still doing and we do every
day,
is to bring Owen closer and closer to
that man village that we all inhabit.
There's so much hope in that and as he
progressed, as you feel so good about it,
but at the same time,
that's not to say he'll
ever totally get there.
[inaudible]
as hard as we might
try, we, we may not get,
but that doesn't mean you,
you leave him on the path,
you stay with him on the path,
even if it's a never ending path.
[inaudible]
thanks to Ron Suskind. Cornelia
says, kind of waltz us, kind, Owens,
us kind of the whole Suskind
family and Mr Sass guidance book.
Ryan's book is called life animated,
takes also to Jonathan Freeman,
Elaine Hall, Steve
Silberman, Pamela doodle Var,
and Kelsey [inaudible] and Cynthia.
Thanks also to Gill,
tippy and the Tina McCort at the Rebecca
school and to the whole staff at that
school. They're all heroes in
my mind here. So there you go.
There you go. I'm Chad. I'm Ron. I'm
Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.